in this corner one of the most pitilest
landscapes in the world
Aaron Australian Outback
in this corner one of the most resilient
survivors in the world the red kangaroo
with survival skills shaped by millions
of years of evolution it's now handed on
knockout Arch a devastating drought
as thousands succumbed to dehydration
and starvation one remarkable route may
be facing death
can he make it through this hell on
Earth or is this one fight even the red
kangaroo
thank you
Australia the oldest continent on the
planet almost three quarters of it looks
like this
at its Center it gets five inches of
rain a year
[Music]
Mercury can hit 110 degrees Fahrenheit
the hardest part for those who live here
is the climate's unpredictable
personality
is a place where there are no true
seasons
only moods
to make it here
you need to roll with the punches
and shift gears in a hurry
the acknowledged master of that art in
the Australian outback is the red
kangaroo
the largest marsupial in the world
[Music]
this female is pregnant
red kangaroo females are almost always
pregnant
they evolve to adapt their reproductive
systems to the unpredictable whims of
the environment
[Music]
at any given moment a female can have
three Offspring to care for each at a
different stage of development
[Music]
this is number one
the peanut
after 33 days developing in the womb the
newborn emerges as a blind hairless pink
creature
roughly the size of a peanut we call him
Rusty
[Music]
there's virtually no sign of the
powerful hind legs we all associate with
the kangaroo
arms to make the grueling Trek up the
belly to his mother's nipple guided
solely by Instinct and smell
[Music]
almost immediately the female goes into
heat again releasing hormones that
stimulate ovulation once fertilized the
mother's endocrine system puts the
development of this new embryo on hold
that's Offspring number two
the embryo won't continue its
development until the peanut reduces his
suckling
number three is the Joey he spends some
time suckling from outside the pouch and
some out on his own in the big wide
world
[Music]
the female is a living assembly line of
young at various stages of development
but when times are hard the system has
to be ruthless she will cut off
nutrition to the peanut in her pouch and
when it dies she'll restart the embryo's
development to take his place
[Music]
Rusty's growing up
he's beginning to resemble something
like a baby kangaroo
foreign
[Music]
s of the world he'll soon be joining
it's also unfamiliar
so it's not surprising he'd prefer to
stay in the pouch a bit longer
[Music]
there's plenty of food around now and
Rusty's mom makes the most of the good
grazing
she doesn't eat much but needs a
particular type of grass for her
nutrition the shorter and Greener the
better
she'll need to eat Hardy it's not a
matter of whether hard times will come
it is just a matter of when
and Rusty needs the nutrition too
it takes a lot of energy to grow ears
like these
he's also starting to sprout fur so Mom
has to modify his milk to supply more
protein
by the time he leaves the pouch the fat
content of his milk supply will have
doubled to be almost twice that of cow's
milk preparing him nutritionally for an
active life outside the pouch
[Music]
and Rusty has already been surveying his
new world
about seven months ago Rusty crawled
into this world with arms twice as long
as his legs as Mom relaxes her pouch
muscles to release him
his legs are now more than twice as long
as his arms
[Music]
but Rusty's not the only one in the
neighborhood with a serious set of legs
foreign
the biggest native bird in Australia
announces his arrival
[Music]
his skirt of feathers absorbs 80 percent
of solar radiation leaving the skin
underneath cool
[Music]
and this Dad needs a cool head
in the Emu World dads take on all
parental responsibility
[Music]
thank you
the chicks will be under his wing for 18
months
not exactly the red kangaroo way males
are pretty much deadbeat dads they leave
as soon as the young are conceived
Rusty still relies on his mother for
food and protection so he tends to stay
close
but apparently he's got an independent
streak
maybe there's even more fun out there
soon he leaves the rest of the mob
and finds himself in Uncharted Territory
[Music]
place for a baby kangaroo to be
wedge-tailed eagle
the largest bird of prey in Australia
likes to snatch young kangaroos
mom realizes she doesn't know where
Rusty is
but the eagle does
Rusty's big ears and instincts tell him
something's not right he's just too
young and inexperienced to know what it
is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ER has Rusty left his mother's side that
he's in trouble
with the bone crushing power of her
talents
it's Rusty and drag him to his death
Gloria panicked activity nearby
a rabbit runs for his life
[Music]
luckily for Rusty there's easier prey to
be had this time
[Music]
red kangaroos and wedge-tailed Eagles
share the same territory
and when the eagle has a chick to feed
the hunting never stops
more than 10 percent of the Eagles diet
is kangaroo
foreign
[Music]
Rusty is now eight months old and a
full-fledged Joey a juvenile that spends
all his time outside the pouch
[Music]
he won't have mom's milk to rely on
anymore
[Music]
she'll taper off his milk supply
because there's another peanut on the
way and it needs the nutrition
mom's body now produces two totally
different types of milk a more dilute
one for his tiny sister
and a richer one for him
dispensed from its own nipple
but males like Rusty are about 10
percent larger at weaning than the
average female
and are heavy drinkers
[Music]
this is the kangaroo version of tough
love
Rusty's mother Cuts him off completely
her milk is needed elsewhere
[Music]
now Rusty's off to explore his wider
world
[Music]
before law he finds another group of
kangaroos
[Music]
these are gray kangaroos smaller than
Reds and more suited to areas where the
climate is relatively predictable
they don't conserve water as well as
Reds and prefer the shade of the wooded
areas on the desert's Edge
Rusty's apparently a new experience for
them as well it's like a get-together
with distant relatives you've heard of
but never met
slightly awkward
[Music]
here comes another branch of the family
wallaroos marsupials somewhere between
red kangaroos and wallabies in size who
frequent the rocky outcrops looking for
shade and water
if you live in the desert water is a
treasure and its presence is never
guaranteed
the only certainty
is unpredictability
a water hole is a gift from the heavens
for many creatures
[Music]
Reds and walaroos all gathered to drink
but the Relentless sun is turning the
mud around the water hole into clay
laying traps for the unwary
Rusty is not driven by the same intense
thirst as his gray cousins
Reds have a kind of super kidney which
concentrates their urine so they hold on
to more water
Grays have to drink more frequently
and their thirst can drive them to
unwise decisions
[Music]
this young gray is in trouble deep
trouble
and he's drawing some unwanted attention
a dingo
dingos will gladly take a young kangaroo
under any circumstances
a joey stuck in the mud unable to flee
that's just too good to resist the other
kangaroos can't help him his fate is
sealed
even at the tender age of 18 months
Rusty has the good sense to get out of
Dodge in a hurry
a dingo is stalking the area
[Music]
kangaroo Mobs Can number in the hundreds
but this one is relatively small
[Music]
Rusty's appearance on the scene catches
another male's attention
same size and the same age perfect
spotting buddies
[Music]
a game on
a life or death battle
[Music]
what they learn here will be crucial
later in life when the stakes are higher
long arms for wrestling win fights and
females want winners
[Music]
Rusty doesn't come out on top this time
but the boxing experience is invaluable
at this age the learning curve for a
kangaroo is steep
and full of surprises
a sudden rustle in the dry grass Spooks
the Gang
but Rusty's the Curious type A shingle
back lizard
heavily armored and with a big tail that
looks a lot like its head
s it its other name the two-headed skink
Rusty wants to know what he's supposed
to do with this
[Music]
friends
try to box with it
eat it the lizard doesn't seem suitable
for any of these activities
Rusty eventually gives up on the
relationship
[Music]
this part of the central Australian
Outback has been hot and dry for weeks
the plants are picked clean
when food sources dry up like this red
kangaroos are superbly adapted to
survive
still
they can't live without water
but something is happening 100 miles
away
[Music]
where the sky is opened up and
torrential rains are soaking the parched
Earth
these Waters will end up in the channel
country and be funneled Inland hundreds
of miles away from their origin
the channels are dry now but the region
is low lying so they won't be for long
[Music]
now what was once an arid Wasteland
begins to revive
[Music]
from the swirling flocks of budgery guys
to the dingo mom and her pups all are
drawn to the life-giving waters
thank you
the young Eagle flexes its new feathers
and a young kangaroo celebrates in her
own playful way
[Music]
emus are water guzzlers and adults can
drink up to four gallons a day
[Music]
like all emails the chicks reveled the
cooling back
[Music]
there are some half a million Innings
roaming around the Outback grazing on
fruits and seas
and what's good for emus is good for the
rest of the ecosystem
Bush they scatter the seeds of flowers
and fruit they've eaten along the way
which will eventually Sprout and become
new plants
the weeks turn into months
Rusty is now five years old and in Prime
condition
food has been his overriding concern
but now other impulses drive him
he's making the rounds of this gang
sniffing the females to pick out the
receptive ones
he's now twice the size of some
potential mates
but he's not quite in the size class of
this bad boy
[Music]
this is the king of the mob
male Reds grow throughout most of their
lives
he looks like he's had a few brawls in
his day and he has about 50 pounds on
Rusty big males who lose battles can be
faced with a complete shutdown of their
reproductive system Rusty knows he's not
ready for this bout and wisely
withdrawals
Rusty Was Born to Run looking for mating
Partners fleeing from predators
traveling to Fine Food
Reds really shine when it's time to
Sprint
the red kangaroo has one of the most
efficient aerobic physiologies of any
mammal better than a racehorse and a lot
better than us
its heart is much bigger than you'd
expect in twice the size of the deers
a full half of Rusty's mass is muscle
with 80 being concentrated around his
pelvis and upper hind legs putting him
among the most muscular animals in the
world
they're so efficient that they actually
use less energy to breathe when they're
hopping than when they're at rest
[Music]
red kangaroos are built to get where
they want to go unfortunately sometimes
especially when they're inexperienced
they get someplace they really don't
want to be
[Music]
[Applause]
the inland taipan is the most toxic
snake on earth
one bite has enough Venom to kill 100
full-grown men
[Music]
and this Taipan specializes in killing
mammals
the Australian desert is the kingdom of
reptiles and kangaroos know to leave all
snakes alone
brown snakes kill more humans than any
other snakes in Australia
[Music]
it's not the biggest reptile in the
neighborhood this is
the parenting reaching eight feet long
venomous and fast on its feet a large
parenti will eat a small kangaroo
today it's got its eye on an eastern
brown snake
foreign
[Music]
Ty follows the brown snake's chemical
scent Trail and leads him to an
abandoned bird
a burrow with only one entrance
parenting in the picture a sanctuary can
easily become a death
[Music]
the body of one fearsome reptile
disappears into the body of another
good
[Music]
the months roll on and Rusty has grown
in both size and experience
he weighs 150 pounds now and has dozens
of sparring matches under his belt
today he finds himself with a mob he
knows
foreign
the one with the tough male who
intimidated him last time
[Music]
that was five years ago and Rusty's not
running away this time
[Music]
tries to attack his rival's head
keeping his own head back out of range
although highly ritualized fights
between dominant males can mean a future
as king or a loner depending on the
outcome
don't want those damaged
Rusty with darker fur puts up a good
fight
but the alpha male is more experienced
females don't care who wins just as long
as he's got good genes
Rusty is younger than his opponent and
in top fighting four
[Music]
fine the King goes down
now the mob pays him attention
thank you
Rusty's the top male and The Winner
Takes all
[Music]
his first choice is this female
though he needs to give her urine the
sniff test to make sure she's ovulating
she's ready
Rusty has only a brief window of
opportunity
she may be receptive for only a matter
of hours
better get to it
mating doesn't take long
or wouldn't if there were only one
female to consider
but Rusty's got miles to go before he
sleeps
he's King kangaroo now and in addition
to regular mating duties he'll have to
fend off young Roos who'd like to knock
him off his throne just as he did his
predecessor but that's not all rusty has
to worry about the temperature is
soaring and the land is drying out
evaporation is sucking the life out of
everything
you can never tell when the weather will
change only that it will
and that's the origin of some of the red
kangaroos most amazing adaptations
they are masters of heat regulation
[Music]
fur on their backs reflects about 30
percent of incoming heat and keeps their
skin cool the blue parts of this thermal
footage
spreading saliva over their forearms
cools the blood which has been brought
close to the skin surface via a dense
cobweb of capillaries
foreign
[Music]
with temperatures simmering above 100
degrees for over a week a third of the
males have already become infertile it s
temperatures continue for three more
months the number would more than double
Reds defend their sperm by licking their
scrotums to keep them cool and in
contrast to their battle strategy of
retracting the scrotum males let their
testicles hang way down below their
overheated trunks
about seven degrees cooler than at their
course
the sand even a few inches down is
cooler than at the surface
red kangaroos dig until they reach
cooler soil and then
it hasn't rained for months now
the dry dead grass offers Rusty no
nourishment
[Music]
foreign
unfortunately these are dry electrical
storms no rain will come from them
but something else will
something worse than hunger
lightning ignited the dry grass of the
Outback
almost 10 percent of arid Australia can
burn like this in a single year
in a matter of hours the fire consumes
what little forage there is Rusty has to
move on
but there's really nowhere to go
not this time
parts of desert Australia are in the
grip of a once in a century drought
while heat waves smash temperature
records
foreign
[Music]
s here has ever experienced anything
like it Rusty included
[Music]
some suffer from severe malnutrition and
dehydration but if anyone can survive
this it's a red kangaroo human bodies
are about 60 percent water Rusty's is
more than 70 percent
in a heat wave like this he can survive
levels of dehydration that would kill
most humans
it's only sweat when they're on the move
at rest they pant which uses less water
than sweating
raising their breathing rate to over 200
breaths a minute reduces their deep body
temperature and cools their brains
and of course they cover their limbs in
cooling saliva
but there's a price to pay licking uses
up precious water if the drought
continues much longer this form of
cooling will be too costly
[Music]
the kangaroos stay under whatever shade
they can find
times get this tough females switch off
their milk supply
maternal instinct is strong but
self-preservation is stronger
unwaned Offspring outside the pouch are
the first to die and young in the
pouches are next as it dies the female
reactivates her waiting embryo but if
the drought persists it too will die and
she will stop reproducing all together
even Rusty one of the strongest is in
trouble
in these conditions males are the first
to succumb especially the largest who
like Rusty need more food
[Music]
thank you
the demise of a red kangaroo is the
wedge-tailed Eagles bounty
foreign
[Music]
but it's not just kangaroos that are
suffering
the drought takes its toll everywhere
[Music]
to turn on each other to protect a tiny
piece of rancid meat
[Music]
this is the last remaining Waterhole
thank you
it's stagnant and salty
ordinarily animals would never drink
this water
[Music]
but desperation drives them
foreign
this is a sign of things to come
[Music]
eat waves in Australia are becoming
hotter and more frequent
[Music]
the intense dry heat continues and the
casualties mount
among them are many of Rusty's offspring
in some parts of these desolate lands
drought can kill eight out of every 10
kangaroos
[Music]
Australia's desert inhabitants are a
resilient bunch
after all these may have been the
hottest temperatures for the last
hundred years and this species has
successfully weathered their hot climate
for tens of thousands of years
[Laughter]
Rusty is still here conserving his
energy and biting his time
But A change is going to come
this does
after 12 months of merciless drought the
landscape is dotted with the remains of
those that could not hang on any longer
but in the Australian Outback all bad
things come to an end
eventually
thunder clouds Gather in the distance
[Music]
a change in the weather
somewhere there is rain and where there
is water there will soon be food
just has to get there
[Music]
with what remains of his ebbing strength
Rusty heads in the direction of a storm
as do the other red kangaroos who have
made it this far
[Music]
when Rusty reaches the area watered by
the storms he finds a world restored by
rain
[Music]
plenty to eat plenty to drink
you can almost see the relief and joy in
their hopping
[Music]
this will stay here and take in the
nourishment in only a few weeks males
and females will have their health
restored and soon they'll be ready to
reproduce once again
[Laughter]
[Music]
but before that can happen they have to
make it through this
a pack of hungry dingoes
[Music]
hunting in a pack more than doubles a
dingo's success rate
normally they'd go for the weakest
kangaroos in the group but a pack of
this size can take down something bigger
something like Rusty
[Music]
his strength is completely restored and
he can travel at Full Tilt
oh
it doesn't accelerate by bounding faster
but by bounding further
he lengthens his leaps at times covering
25 feet in a single bound
once he gets past 10 miles an hour
rusting Rockets along with little extra
effort while the dingo's four legs need
to move ever faster
[Music]
at 25 miles an hour Rusty's using only
about half of the energy the dogs are
putting in they have no chance of
catching him
oh
now Rusty can turn his attention to
replacing The Offspring lost to the
drought
[Music]
thank you
at 200 powerful pounds and in the prime
of light
there's no question that he's the
dominant male in this gang
[Music]
the young he fathers will need an
advantage to survive a world as harsh
and unpredictable as this one
what greater Advantage could there be
than to begin life as the progeny of
Undisputed King of the red kangaroo mom
[Music]
foreign